le géant français total annoncé son
retrait de l'association canadienne des
producteurs pétroliers est aussi une
dépréciation d'actifs de plus de 9
milliards de dollars
qu'est ce que ça signifie pour les
sables bitumineux canadiens quel message
également ça envoie j'en discute avec
eric pinon économiste et professeur au
département de sociologie de l'uqam
bonjour monsieur pinault oui bonjour ça
semble clair maintenant le géant total
ne croient plus du tout dans l'avenir
des sables bitumineux canadiens
non du tout le gel total comme beaucoup
d'autres grandes multinationales du
pétrole se retire c'était la dernière
grande entreprise multinationale de dali
dans les sables bitumineux on sait que
shell était déjà parti bp aurait été
plus ou moins impliqués donc c'est la
dernière et ces investissements étaient
pas significatif dans son portefeuille
d'actifs on peut dire que le s'habitue
lui c'était une petite partie de ce
cadre et comme actif et elle a décidé
donc de dévaluer puis quitté
l'association qui représente les
extracteurs ouais on parle d'une
dépréciation gamin qui est importante le
même sens sur ses actifs l'objectif mais
voilà exactement et parce qu'on sait
actuellement puis c'est notamment dans
leurs justificatifs c'est plus
dispendieux de sortir le pétrole des
sables bitumineux que le pétrole normal
qu'on le voit encore aujourd'hui les
cours du pétrole sont en recul
la question est ce que c'est encore
viable de produire du pétrole albertain
est ce que c'est encore viable sa
dépendance au pétrole dont on parle si
on parle du pétrole issu des sables
bitumineux est un grand problème c'est
un double problème je dirais le premier
problème c'est le coût d'extraction le
coût d'extraction est plus élevé que les
autres méthodes plus traditionnelles
mais ce qui est surtout extrêmement
élevé c'est l'investissement initial
pour expo pauvres s'installer pour
installer une infrastructure donc ce qui
est ce qui est problématique
l'essab itunes us et l'expansion de la
production ou le remplacement à mesure
qu'on et puis certains gisements ne leur
emplacement avec eux en ouvrant des
nouveaux gisements sort ça prend des
prix beaucoup plus élevés que les prix
qui ont cours actuellement le faudrait
et dans des 70 à 100 de leur nid dans
cet espace là
l'on est plutôt tendue 40 à 60 77 on
peut de m'extraire on peut faire un peu
d'argent pour en extraire mais mais pas
tant deuxième problème c'est que total
comme bien d'autres producteurs de
pétrole
the tendent vers la qualité un peu en
vue ce que ça veut dire ça veut surtout
dire de diminuer l'empreinte carbone de
son modèle d'affaires et d'instants
alors ce qu'on fait c'est quand on
regarde tous ses actifs et on les classe
selon les plus dommageables en termes de
plus grand émetteur de gérer ce but
faible puis on raye le haut de la liste
est bien des sables bitumineux sont en
haut de la liste
c'est noté carbone clairement pour eu
les arbitres ne sont plus polluante que
le pétrole
normal c'est connu les sables bitumineux
compte tenu de la méthode d'extraction
continue de la qualité la ressource
qu'on a on commence c'est à dire un
goudron très épais c'est inévitable
malgré tous les efforts qu'on occupe
seul ou dans les vingt dernières années
pour diminuer la signature de les
émissions la signature carbone du de ce
pétrole là il demeure plus élevé que les
autres pétrole un régal différence avec
les sables bitumineux plus conventionnel
de conventionalité des gisements sous
pression dit m fuyons dentaire qui veut
sortir les sables bitumineux c'est un
mélange de goudron pitt semble alors si
c'est évident que en termes de défendre
d'extraction ça demande beaucoup plus
d'énergie way home est par contre on
avait l'impression la boc l'industrie
avait fait des efforts et d'ailleurs il
ya une réaction épidermique donc du
ministre la bo de l'énergie on l'a dit
nous on fait des efforts les tenthrèdes
et réduit les gaz à effet de serre
clairement pour total ces pôles coll non
parce que du point de vue de la liberté
oui on est réduit et c'est à dire que
par exemple une des méthodes pour
séparer le sable du pétrin du goudron en
fait qui va devenir du pétrole c'est en
chauffant il faut chauffer à très haute
température on utilise la vapeur et
comme ça on peut se séparer le sable du
pétrole on met tout chauffé ça me rend
de la vapeur pour la vapeur une fois
généré traditionnellement on faisait ça
à charbon depuis quelques années on mail
vers le gaz naturel donc l'on fait des
gains en termes de réduction de ges mais
ça c'est la référence la ccc les sables
bitumineux
mais si on se donne comme référence le
pétrole qu'on exprès dans le monde
ben là le même sont fait des efforts on
demeure qu on part de tellement loin que
ça demeure un pétrole qui est
extrêmement polluant qu'un parent à dos
ainsi je suis j'utilise l'exemple
souvent un peu en vue en disant un
gâteau des enjeux complexes hugues
l'armée savent un gâteau des enjeux
c'est de faire un gâteau des anges de la
mélasse lui ça serait pas la même chose
mais si en plus c'est la différence
entre pétrole des sables bitumineux
puits de pétrole convention comprend
l'image monsieur pinault au total
également qu'ils ne voient plus le
pétrole cher alors on voit plus du tout
un baril de pétrole à 100 dollars 150
dollars et même on a une demande qui va
descendre à environ 10 n
oui on travaille est totale et passeur
bp et shell les trois ont à peu près le
même scénario un ce qu'on appelle un pic
de demande entre 20 et 30 20 40 qui est
très différent par exemple d'impérial
d'ex en nous des extracteurs canadiens
comme suncor qu'ils ont misé sur un
bonne progression légère de la demande
jusqu'à 20 50 tandis que du côté total
non s'attend à ce que les politiques
climatiques en europe en particulier
mais ailleurs dans le monde en asie en
chine pour ses économies il a diminué
les la demande un peu en pétrole en
particulier secteur du transport on
s'attend des gains importants et donc ça
veut dire que y'a plus de pétrole super
que on va devoir brûler finalement cours
à courir moyen terme
donc la demande cloud dans ce temps-là
tu regardes deux affaires tu regardes le
prix que ça coûte à extraite du dimanche
vos jeux vos mettre sur le marché ce qui
est le plus rentable et tu regardes
parce que les politiques climatiques
parce que les politiques
environnementales un peu partout sa
planète tu regarde aussi le pétrole qui
il est moins polluant halki que j'ai le
moins de co2 et c'est lui qui va mettre
aux marches sur le marché alors s'y
habituer les perdants sur les deux les
deux tableaux il est perdante côté les
émissions de giresse puis le perdant du
côté de des coûts d'extraction
ce soit pire je demande et d'offre
rapidement je le seul à vous entendre on
parle du pétrole est un petit mot sur le
prix à la pompe pourquoi c'est aussi
cher alors que le prix de la matière est
à son plus beau mais parce que ce qu'ils
nous vendent une grande partie de ce
qu'ils nous vendent à la pompe sont ceux
qu'ils extraient et quand le prix du
baril est beau et bien tu rates rapt et
profite d'un final haletant distribution
raffinage et distribution c'est les deux
endroits dans le fond ils gagnent
entreprises intégrées comme bp et
andalous shell ou impérial qui me donne
les sauts ici ou suncor avec les pétro
canada 4 watts à trois segments dans le
raffinage milieu un boot à l'extraction
pialot bhutto la pompe
et dans le fond tu es toujours en train
de jouer un jeu pour maintenir son taux
de profit de ses trois segments dont
quatre super un endroit tassé de gagner
à l'eau tendre merci beaucoup de ces
explications et répit dont bonne soirée
merci